good morning believe nation today's
message is make your own decisions over
to you robert de niro personally i
always try to listen because i might be
not and maybe I'm not getting something
I always try and take everybody's
because it's important to listen to
everyone as many people as you can and
get their input but then finally you
have to make your own decision about
what you're gonna do and that's it
that's what you feel and that's it and
that that's the most important thing I
think the most important thing because
that's where the uniqueness comes in
because it's you you've done it it's
your thing it's not anybody else's it's
your choice so I like the town Alex
who's on my team who's the operations
manager of Toronto Dane salsa has been a
friend of the channel here has been on a
couple times I like to tell him that I'm
open until I'm not and this is my
process of making decisions we're at the
start I have a vision I have an idea but
it's not concrete yet I'm still trying
to figure a lot of stuff out I may have
an idea of the emotional reaction I want
people to have or what the final product
may look like but there's a lot of steps
that are still missing right I have a
general concept but a lot of the holes
are still there
and so I'm open I'm talking I'm asking
questions what do you think I need your
input and then I'm not open right you
get to the point where okay I made a
decision this is what I want to do this
is what we're doing when I was talking
about anymore now we're going to execute
because if all you're doing is taking
feedback constantly and you don't make
up your mind and you don't have your own
stake in the ground then you never get
anything done then you try to do
everything by committee and that's not
the way to build something unique and to
really build a company I find that when
you have expertise you can get there a
lot faster and when you're still
learning it may take you a little bit
longer to come to your own decision as
an example I'm writing the book now this
is my first book that I've ever written
there's a lot of stuff that I don't know
about a lot of things that unfamiliar
about I'm documenting the process and
journey in the Evans book series so
because I don't know about it I'm taking
a lot of feedback and I'm asking a lot
of questions I'm asking my friends I'm
asking people in the industry I'm asking
people don't know anything about the
industry just who read
I'm assuming we don't read books you
know I'm getting feedback from all sorts
of different sources and it's taking me
longer to get to a decision on some of
the things that I need to make the
changes on because I've never done it
before where if you look at speaking or
my youtube channel or the salsa business
or a lot of other things that I have
more experience in I can get there a lot
faster because I had the experience and
so for you guys I encourage you to take
feedback in listen to others see what
works for you see what feels right right
like listen to your gut but then you
need to make your own decision right you
got to do the thing that you feel is
best I'm open until I'm not so the
question of the day today is I'm curious
what was the last decision that you
really owned the last decision that
somebody may have hated on or didn't
agree with or made you feel a little bit
uncomfortable you said you put your flag
in the ground and said this is where
we're going this is what I'm going to do
what was that decision leave it in the
comments below and I'll join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching and have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso